Kerry lake is apparently Staffing up for
a senate campaign this would be the
campaign to take Kirsten cinnamon seat
Kirsten Cinema is a Democrat but she's
kind of moderate and she's now an
independent so she's running as an
independent you've got a Democrat now
who's running Reuben Gallego and you've
got a Pinal County Sheriff Mark Lamb
who's running as a republican Kerry Lake
might challenge him to be the Republican
nominee this also makes sense Carrie
lake has to run for something because
she needs to set herself up to be the
vice president so Carrie like has been
not so subtly campaigning to be the vice
presidential running mate with Donald
Trump but right now she's just a lady
who lost a gubernatorial election so she
she needs something to give her the
credibility to take that position the
Arizona senate seat would make a lot of
sense